es klingt fremd und doch vertraut dass
cookies werk lied neu arrangiert
durchdrungen von klängen aus dem orient
die syrische und schweizer musiker
zueinander finden und miteinander
musizieren davon soll dieser bericht
handelt
erwin mahmud lebt seit zwei jahren in
bern
die anwältin musste syrien verlassen zu
gefährdet war sie durch ihre arbeit für
eine kurdische
menschenrechtsorganisation vital doc
marx der als fotograf und kameramann für
die syrische opposition gearbeitet hatte
vor einem jahr fand er asyl in der
schweiz
hier am bahnhof in bern warten wir auf
die beiden musiker die wir porträtieren
wollen auf die sängerin nadja zu lehmann
und den komponisten hass antara die in
der schweiz eine neue künstlerische
heimat suchen und auf dem weg sind zu
einem konzert heute stellen wir ihnen
zwei künstler aus einem herrlichen land
vor dass der krieg in ein grab
verwandelt hat und aus denen die
kreativen künstler vertrieben wurden die
beiden heißen hassan sie wollen die
orientalische volksmusik wiederbeleben
und mit schweizer musik aus alten zeiten
verbinden sie wollen brücken bauen
zwischen vergangenheit und gegenwart von
orient und okzident wir wollen von einem
anderen ziel in erzählen nicht immer nur
vom elend von krieg von flucht und
vertreibung
denn hassan taha und nacho suleman
stehen für eine weltoffene syrische
kultur die versucht grenzen einzureißen
nicht aufzubauen
obwohl oder gerade weil die erinnerungen
ständig präsent sind
eigentlich studiert zurückkommen nach
syrien und mein projekt weiter zu machen
und bin ich immer auch
hans in syrien war geht in dem al assad
regime und seine league titel
mentalität man lebt durch das ist mein
main landes dem strich muss dort kämpfen
durch meine musik unserem land ist der
stift jetzt leute stellten es gibt kein
leben mehr durch es gibt nur zerstörung
und so ist die können nicht zurückgehen
machule mal hat in damaskus gesang
studiert viele konzerte gegeben und auch
gesang unterrichtet rasante lernte sie
während des studiums kennen
er spielte im syrischen
sinfonieorchester waldhorn aber sein
traum war es immer zu komponieren
er studierte in den niederlanden und an
der musikhochschule in bern
als der krieg begann die beiden
konfrontieren ihre vergangenheit mit
einer anderen vergangenheit oder
hinterlassenschaft diese gegenwärtig
umgibt wie in ihrem neuen projekt
brunnen und brücken an dem sie mit dem
schweizer musiker hans martin stähle
arbeiten
das ist für mich wie beim spielen des
alten guggisberg liedes so dass ich eine
solche intensität von durchdringung von
orientalischem jetzt und und diesem
schweizerischen kaum je erlebt habe also
es ist für mich eine verschmelzung von
orient und okzident wie ich es kaum
besser überleben könnte für mich ist das
nicht nur eine musikalische projekt aber
ist wie ein eine nostalgie nach unserem
leben in syrien es musste nicht bleiben
in der vergangenheit aber ich suche nach
diese verbindung zwischen vergangenheit
und diesem moment